[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Give me
one minute, and I'll
show you how BeyondCorp
Enterprise can secure access
to your services from
beyond the corporate walls.
Companies are increasingly
more distributed,
as employees work
in more locations.
Connecting to a VPN can be
slow for employees located
far away from the headquarters.
However, granting flat access
to internal labs based only
on the network can
also be dangerous.
With a network-centric
model, attackers
can exfiltrate data just by
gaining access to the network.
To solve these problems,
BeyondCorp Enterprise
pushes security checks from
the network back to the user's
device and context.
It does this by creating
a proxy in front
of apps running in GCP,
other Cloud platforms,
or on premises.
The proxy passes through
or blocks traffic
based on the requester's device
information, their identity,
and hundreds of other signals.
For example, you can choose
to allow access to HR apps
only for devices
managed by the company.
For added security, you
can enforce multifactor
authentication as well.
To secure HR apps using
Access Context Manager,
Define an access level.
This level includes
requests from devices
managed by the company
and requests authenticated
with multifactor.
Next, using Identity
Aware Proxy,
map the new access
level to the HR web app.
So next time you're
looking to shift
to a zero-trust,
context-diverse security model,
take a minute to look at
BeyondCorp Enterprise.
To learn more check, out
cloud.google.com/beyondcorp
enterprise.